se saluer tout en équilibrant l'espace
scénique l'un des premiers enseignements
que l'on apprend au théâtre depuis lundi
29 avril sont huit à bénéficier les
conseils d'une professionnelle
une première pour le prisme des locaux
ce stage s'inscrit dans le cadre de
notre programmation vacances créatives
qui viennent de se mettre en place cette
saison
l'idée c'était de pouvoir proposer à des
enfants de passer leurs vacances dans un
théâtre avec une activité artistique
travail sur le corps relation à l'autre
articulation autant d'exercices abordé
toute la journée sous la direction
d'evelyne bages et comédienne depuis 40
ans le plus important pour elle c'est de
donner la parole à ces jeunes élèves
on apprend des choses on s'amuse
le professeur est super sympa enfin on
fait plein de trucs que moi j'avais pas
fait de stage avant et pas du tout de
théâtre et du coup bah j'ai appris plein
de choses on travaille sur des exercices
de mise en scène et aussi sur notre voie
nos mouvements pleins de l'exercice qui
font un peu des enfants qui font
référence un peu au théâtre des émotions
travail et la colère le dégoût la
tristesse avec l'aide de leurs
professeurs ils ont créé plusieurs
saynètes ont laisseront libre cours à
leur imagination
les petits comédiens ont encore jusqu'à
vendredi pour parfaire leur prestation
avant de se représenter sur scène devant
leurs parents le prisme prévoit déjà une
deuxième édition de ses vacances
créatives pour le mois d'avril
m